Wallahi, I need wife. 2020 60's on the
way.
>> Brother, look how handsome you are. Is
the girls gone blind?
This is the new Sadaqah Jariyah in town.
Just imagine this. You help someone
learn wudu, how to pray.
>> [music]
>> How to recite Surah Al-Fatiha. Every
Fajr Zuhr Asr Maghrib
>> Isha Tahajjud
>> Tarawih Every prayer for the rest of
their lives you share in the reward.
>> When they teach their children and their
children's children the reward continues
[music] for you. For just 100 pounds you
can help teach 20 to 60 people
>> like me learn salah. Donate today and
earn rewards that never stop.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh brothers and sisters and dear
friends, hope you guys are well
inshallah. Subhanallah, you guys might
know
of a brother called Max
who came to our dawah table about a
month or month and a half ago. He was
making a little bit of jokes, etc. He
was there when I was giving some nasiha
to uh Pilot. Uh Subhanallah, he was
actually there with when the whole
discussion was happening. Uh
Subhanallah, when Pilot was there and I
was trying to give him some nasiha
whatever it's for that matter. And he
came to the dawah table and was just
making joke about wanting to get
married, you know, and I said, you know,
Subhanallah, you know, you're a handsome
you're a handsome guy, you know, is is
the sisters around your area gone blind,
Subhanallah, as a joke. And this video
actually went really viral. Wallahi, I
need wife. 2020 60's on the way.
Brother, look how handsome you are. Is
the girls gone blind?
These these girls are blind where you
live. You need to go somewhere where
they can see. How is a handsome man like
you have no wife? Okay. If I speak to
sister, can I say I want to marry you?
Is this allowed to speak to her or is it
haram? Yes, it's not haram, but it's
about how you go about it. But be
careful, she might be married. Okay. Or
if her brother is there, he might be
peak. But if you approach in a decent
way
Okay. Can I speak to the sister?
You can approach by saying, "Look, my
intentions are this. Can I speak to your
guardian?" Yeah, okay. Oh, you can say,
"Can I have your dad number?" Yeah.
>> yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. You have to, you
have to, yeah. I can tell you you can
say, "Can I just get your dad number?"
Yeah.
>> Yeah, yeah.
Come on, brother. You're Come on.
Okay, I take that somebody.
Subhanallah and today we in the group we
had a message saying there was some
there's always rumors that he was
stabbed and then there was another
brother who told me I was going to say
he done it on purpose this what he heard
that apparently he was stabbed he was in
the hospital he died in the scene he
died in the hospital etc. And
Subhanallah firstly we want to obviously
um
Dawood knows more information cuz you
know the the family.
But Subhanallah we just entered the
first
um
night or should we say the first odd
night of the last 10 nights. Subhanallah
Laylatul Qadr and I ask you guys to make
the most of it death is like you know
and he was filming brother Latif's
Janazah
live streaming it Subhanallah for those
who couldn't attend and I urge you guys
brothers and sisters to understand that
this life is temporary and I always
mention this verse in the Quran
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala says al hakum ut
takathur hatta zurtumul maqabir kalla
sawfa ta'lamun thumma kalla sawfa
ta'lamun you are busy with the worldly
affairs
until you visit the graves and no surely
you're going to know and Allah says no
surely you will know. Allah's given this
promise a person of certainty gives
promises. You know when someone gets
angry and says wallahi watch and you get
scared like what's what's what's he like
he's speaking very certain.
Allah [clears throat] takes oaths
and Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala is telling
this in the Quran you're busy with the
worldly affairs. Who's going to think
what what of me what car am I driving
what am I wearing? You live for others
even when you're taking snaps and
showing these it's not for yourself it's
for others and the scholars understand
this verse in couple of two ways. Number
one when it says you are busy with the
worldly affairs until you visit the
graves means that when you go and bury
someone.
If we attend the brother's Janazah if we
get a chance inshallah when we go there
we're not going to I'm not going to go
to his grave and be thinking about Rolex
cars this that don't really care about
this stuff anyways but I'm not going to
be going there thinking about the dunya.
So, meaning you are busy with the
worldly affairs that's uh the mufassirin
say until you visit the graves. Meaning,
you get a reality check of what's going
really going to happen. The second way
this mufassirin say is for the one who
visits the grave. Meaning, he's dead.
So, he was busy with the worldly
affairs, the money, the cars, the girls,
etc., the luxury, and whatever it is for
that matter. You're dead. Everyone has a
plan until the angel of death visits
them, bro.
And then you are surely going to know
then. So, at least the first group is
lucky that they came and buried someone
and they take heed, change your ways.
The second one, you're not even going
back. There's no going back. So,
brothers and sisters, wallahi, I urge
you guys to do sadaqah jariyah for
whatever cause.
Gaza, whatever it is, water well, uh
masajid, orphans, whatever. Subhanallah.
And even our own project of Salamat.
Subhanallah. Do it on his behalf.
Remember him as well when you do the
sadaqah jariyah. Teaching people how to
pray salah, how to do wudu, learning
Surah Fatiha, ablution, salah, and
Quran. I'm going to give it to Dawud now
to explain what happened so he can tell
us Subhanallah how this brother passed
away Subhanallah. And most important,
brothers and sisters, the reality of
what is awaiting us. So, Dawud, you
spoke to the family. So, there's rumors
of being stabbed to death, dying on the
scene, dying in the hospital. What's
been happening? What's What's were you
been told? And by who? So, yeah, I spoke
to uh one of my friends, really close
friends. I don't want to disclose his
name. But, um I spoke to him
and he was a family friend to Max.
Um what happened is, first and foremost,
uh to clear the rumors, he was not
stabbed. Okay. He passed away uh in his
uh in his sleep.
Um but, the way he passed away is quite
tragic. Um so, the brother told me that
his one of his aunties was taking care
of Max every now and then.
>> Yeah. And she got concerned because um
you know, she didn't hear of him for
like a couple of weeks now.
Um and him, so my brother, my friend,
went with couple of the brothers to
Max's house.
By the time they got there, they saw his
bike. That his bike was there.
Um when they realized that his bike was
there, they're like, "Okay, he might he
has to be home then." Um they got into
the the the the doorway into the house.
And just by getting into that
smell, and it was a very uh stark stench
that was coming off. And then they broke
into the house.
And they uh found him there. So, he was
there for like couple of weeks.
Um so, yeah. I think yeah, this is one
to clear off these rumors. And two, also
that Max was a very beloved brother.
Subhanallah. I would always see him at
the masjid in Kilburn. I would Yes.
Yeah, I'm going to be honest with you. I
would see him there as well. Now, when
you see someone regularly at masjid,
that means they they are going there so
regularly, people are bumping into him.
Subhanallah. And we should remember him
for that. Yeah.
>> yeah. Masjid and Kilburn, I'll see him.
Cricklewood, I'll see him.
Um so, yeah. May Allah have mercy on
him.
>> Ameen. Ameen.
>> And um like Ali, you were saying, I
think it's very powerful. Brothers and
sisters, take your life serious. Sadaqah
Jariyah with the last 10 days,
subhanallah. We've had this before where
one of our beloved brothers passed away
in the last 10 days. Let this be another
reminder. Brothers and sisters, we at
Salaam, we are a new charity on the
block, subhanallah, that is specializing
in Sadaqah Jariyah. So, if you can,
donate to this cause and make dua for
this brother as well, subhanallah.
Alhamdulillah. Like subhanallah. Um may
Allah bless you that would for that. And
well, everyone says that we ask Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala to forgive him for
his shortcomings and grant him the
highest ranks of Jannah, protect him
from the punishment of the grave, and
have mercy on him. May his righteous
deeds be a companion for him till the
day of judgment. Uh may he be
resurrected among the Muslimin, the
Mumins. Grant him a lofty place. I mean,
wallahi this can be any of us, brothers
and sisters. And wallahi it's so sad to
hear. And you know, I would see him in
Speakers' Corner. I would see him in
Quba Masjid. He would come to our Dawah
table sometimes. Even when I was
speaking to brother Pilot, he would you
know, speak to me, you know, give him
the CR etc. You know, talk to him. So,
you know, subhanallah brothers and
sisters, this is the reality. You know,
and every soul shall taste death,
brothers and sisters. And like I said
before, everyone has a plan until the
angel of death visits them, guys. And
the next thing you're going to be waking
up to is who is your Lord? Yes, you're
going to be thinking, "Oh, I'm going to
be I booked my holiday for 2 weeks. Oh,
I'm buying a house. I'm going to get a
new car. Taking my children to school in
the morning. I need to go see my mom. I
need to do something here, there,
whatever. I'm just going to go to the
corner shop to just buy something."
You wake up to who is your Lord?
And imagine the waste of life that you
give to the dunya and you lose the dunya
in the akhira. Is it worth it? These
last 10 nights, guys, make the most of
your donation, inshallah, brothers and
sisters. May Allah bless and preserve
you guys. Please, if you're going to do
a sadaqah jariyah on
inshallah for yourself and your loved
ones, add and remember brother Max as
well.
Inshallah, whatever it is you're going
to do, be it masjid, be it the salah
matters we're doing, be it water wells,
whatever it is, remember him. And
subhanallah, may Allah bless you guys.
Keep him in your duas. Assalamualaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh.